Louise works for lifespan store she's
responsible for me to to to maintain
video in regards to the loads of items
to various departments so she currently
stores its data in a single loads table
linked to an employee table so it is a
relational database okay to take us one
two three now here's some information
that gives you a little bit of sort of
context for these two tables right the
employee table includes these three
fields these attributes that's fine okay
and then it starts talking about other
kinds of information which appears in
this loans table each department the
department has a single supervisor who
borrows items on behalf of employees now
mark that by the way I'll become crucial
later the supervisors the one borrower
in the items that's why they appear here
but they are borrowing items for the
employees okay so when you're looking at
okay who has borrowed this right it
really is the employee he who who has
the item at is using it okay so that's
why they of here that'll be important
later for when we work out our database
it should play works within a single
department that's fine and each item has
a label attached with the unique item
number okay so the name is not unique as
you can see for instance as two stock
takes care of this excuse me
I'm two stock takes cameras here but
they're different ones alright so here's
some of the records and the first
question that you had to answer on this
one with references of sample data above
identify an example port how many
examples is identify an example
what okay so some of you gave me a few
examples right and there was only one
mark devoted to identifying the example
so if you had like two or three examples
it was still only one mark you like but
I did so much work and I didn't read the
question okay so pay attention there's
one block right pick one out then the
other two marks were described problems
that could arise
consequence okay now right away a few of
you said you identified an example for
me which I'll do it a minute and then
you said now this will result in
unnecessary data being in the database
I'm necessary data being the dimes
unnecessary data being in the database
is not a problem that could arise as a
consequence of that aromasin unnecessary
data being in the database is the
definition of data redundancy okay so
read the question carefully right what's
gonna happen if you've got these kinds
of enough so the to meet examples maybe
you can um call them out now right if
you remember there were two very
commonly easily identified ones what's
what's the biggest one for me that you
can see do you remember
I even just talked about a thirty second
my brain isn't gonna be switched on for
another half hour give me a break okay
so I talked about the item name right
and I said look there's two stay
together okay so an easy way to look for
data redundancy literally is to look for
things which come up multiple times okay
so for instance start a scanner right
it's an easy one to go after because
obviously this field must be quite large
right because it's a text field we know
the way asking works you're gonna need a
one byte for every single character
you're gonna have you know 20 characters
maybe 25 depending on what other kind of
items you've got there so what's the
actual nature of there a Dunnan see the
way that I would say it is
I don't name an item and I'm baack okay
there's data it's duplicated here
really there should be an items table
right should belong somewhere else and
that's got all the names in it and all
that should appear here is just the
number okay so there's one piece of
redundancy there's another one though
and I think it would you mention Otago
yep so you've got the department name
similar kind of problem and you've got
let's see here each department is a
single supervisor right so there's a
one-to-one relationship between these
two pieces of data
remember that one-to-one so you should
never have one-to-one data within a
table it's a real waste of space okay
because if you're going to be this
supervisor you must certainly be in this
department or this supervisor this
department okay so this entire column
should not be here okay it really should
just be one or the other right problem
from who this one okay so there's a
couple of examples ever known it's in
right now some problems I was looking
for you to identify two what's the
what's the when people say is
unnecessary data in the database what
are they what do you probably mean by
that what's the problem with having a
vegetarian why is that an issue well I
don't have as much data as we like it
what effect is I have okay it's so
redundancy and normalization they're
kind of two sides of the same coin the
opposite sides normalization is about
making things more efficient and
redundancies with inefficient but why is
it inefficient what about having all
this unnecessary data that makes it
inefficient yeah it's just bigger it's
bigger I think that's what people mean
when they say this unnecessary data in
them what you really want to say is when
you've got these large fields in here
that are necessary your file size will
be much larger than it needs to be
okay so there's problem number one come
on number two what happens if for
instance okay a department gets a new
supervisor department gets a new
supervisor okay
you tell me what's the problem yeah good
I thought I don't forget to update right
and they'll be like uh-oh you go back
through this table and they'll say ah
ladies where has this so they'll go and
look after whoever this guy is right and
then say you know hey where's this
stocktake scanner that you borrowed and
they'll be like I'm not in things where
anymore i moved to worry about okay so
number one you buy the other problem
that you have in inaccuracies here your
diary integrity will drop as a result of
this inefficiency or alternatively if
you are quite diligent and you're like
oh i should make sure i update this
because you know that purse has changed
you've got to do that every single time
someone changes that's how that's real
pain right so that's what we mean by a
deficient yeah so there's a couple of
problems okay and that's sort of what
really what I was looking for three
months okay right now he pins out or
pencils or whatever whatever you gonna
draw down your heads on because this
next question was a wholesale disaster
okay
full marks for marks the average was
about two I sort of don't blame you like
these questions are not easy okay so you
got to practice these out yes that's
that's why we do trials see that
need to work on this right question
should be it depends on the nature of
your in correct it so sure sorry that's
it that's a that's a maybe but if you if
you're incorrect answer was just like
superfluous information like he said all
this extra stuff which has no relevance
to the question I generally do them but
if it was incorrect information which is
like I misunderstand the nature of the
answer the question that I'm addressing
but I did that quest